like every year mr. Oscar is ready to
take a trip far away from this land the
candidates are already awarded by having
being selected however only one will
take him home tonight
here are the nominees for Best Foreign
Language Film from Spain all about my
mother
Pedro almodóvar from Nepal Caravan Erik
Valley from France east/west Reggie
Daphne a from the United Kingdom Salomon
and gainer Paul Morris newsmen from
Sweden
under the Sun calling nothing
and the Oscar goes to my mother
this is Spain's 18th combination and the
second for direct rope a little while
ago while who was nominated in my
film women on the verge of the nervous
breakdown
my god do you think they are one of the
more beautiful couple
at least Spanish couple you know I come
from a blue country for like you two
very different than this and you know in
that country now is six years in the
morning so let me dedicate this to the
Spanish people that are watching TV now
and they sacrifice their money just to
look you and me with this I mean this is
for Spain
I'm gonna be very quick so if you have
to upload your heart shock how to be
very quick you know I also want to thank
my my sister my nephew's Allen tonyia
for the amount of Congress that they
lead to their favorite Saints during the
last month's you know future different
and thanks to the rebuilding of
Guadalupe a division of la cabeza the
miraculous the Sacred Heart of Mary st.
Judas Tadeo and casues de medina Feli I
told you that we we live in a different
country in a different future a Harvey
Weinstein well listen so forget to have
the one idea what considered my sister's
Oscar campaign you know they they just
lied in a lot of conduct to these saints
presided by a photographer my mother
with Penelope and me next to a twig of
Laurel which brings good luck so I think
now I'm going to believe in all this
well excuse me
thanks thanks to Sonny classic because
really they believe a lot in in our
movie what I'm very quick anyway and of
course
do my brother